where are you right now are you I'm at
my home in Los Angeles yeah yeah it's
going you know I realized that then I
forgot that I knew how to cook so I've
been cooking a lot
I started tweet about the blueberry I go
waffles yeah chicken and waffles my
diets pretty tasty pretty weird but yeah
you find here kind of adjusting to it
yeah is it still just super weird yeah I
am you know I kind of said oh like I was
like freaking out the first two weeks
yeah and then like like maybe like a few
days ago it kind of once it got extended
for us like till like the end of April
or whatever yeah which i think is still
like early i think it's gonna actually
go like much longer but I've kind of
settled and be like okay this is normal
now like this is this is what it is yeah
it's a new way of life for a little bit
you know like I was like I think sorry
was terrible like I was freaking out
unlike cuz I'm pretty extroverted person
person and so like being in my house by
myself with my dog every day is not
ideal yeah but you know once I came to
grips that I was like alright this is
the new normal
like come my mind kind of settled in and
I'm just like running out of things to
watch on Netflix yeah what have you
watched anything that you love oh well I
mean I watched Tiger King obviously I
still need to watch that I've watched
you yeah I just watched this show called
a hip hop evolution which was amazing
okay um started from like you know the
beginning through all the arrows and hip
hop and set which was cool and then
other than that just like cooking a lot
I just bought a new recording program
you know like oh nice job I know is like
are you still working on the album or is
it completely done sounds done yeah
second album is done but we figured you
know we got time so might as well start
making how much communications are
having with Jordan Sam like in this
period we see each other weekly like
we've been each of us have like each of
us have been quarantine
for like two weeks without symptoms and
stuff so like we're good and like we
haven't been you know seeing other
people or like leaving our houses so
like they'll come to my house and like
we'll do like Monday livestreams we do
on Mondays and stuff and then make food
sometimes yeah yeah like I saw you guys
are doing those live streams how those
going free like you like doing those are
they yeah it's interesting I mean we've
never done them really before I don't
think funny because I don't think
anybody had really done them yeah so
it's kind of funny to see everybody like
figure out like how to not be awkward
yeah and have that immediate family
action do like Louie you can read
comments as they're coming in like is
that crazy to see that no that's cool I
mean it's a good way no it's cool it's
like we just announced yesterday that we
had to postpone our North American tour
you know until we figure out new dates
and whatever else which is a bummer but
you know obviously it's for the safety
of of everybody yeah and the stuff which
is the most important thing and so it's
a cool way to like you know just
interact and like play some songs I'm
actually going live again tomorrow or
Friday that's why I know you lose track
of days a little bit yeah literally
there's only three days of the week
yesterday yeah yeah how difficult was
that decision to cancel the tour um I
mean it was I mean it sucked you know
it's it's a bummer because we were yeah
there's the biggest tour we've done yet
and had a lot playing a lot of planning
going into it but you know we can't you
know there's no that's out of our hands
so yeah you know we wanna do I just
stopped the spread of this thing ya know
but you're still released music so waste
came out I guess last Thursday right
okay I love like the 80s sound of it
it's amazing well thank you yeah it's
one of our favorites on the album as
well it's you know good just fun like
different energy for us yeah you said
like it's a little bit outside your guys
comfort zone like why do you think that
um just production wise we kind of just
like
experiment a little bit especially with
like a saxophone and like the your stuff
and which you'll hear a bit more in the
album but you know that one is
definitely like as far that way as we go
do you feel any pressure at all with
like the sophomore album definitely I
mean we had to we have a lot of success
to follow up but you know I go back and
forth with like freaking out and at the
same time being reminding myself that
like that was a moment in time that
happened already you know broken
happened yeah I need hard to smile the
album happened it's never gonna happen
again you know what I mean like the Sun
whatever song we released will never
have the same trajectory is broken did
it might have a similar trajectory or a
bigger trajectory but it's never gonna
have the same life so once like I settle
into that then it's kinda like okay well
it I gotta control what I can control
the music and that work that's music I
can yeah like like is the Alouettes sign
still deliver like you can't change
anything if all the spend you have like
the last me like oh I change that whole
thing yeah it's done it's like yeah
we're in the process of making an
artwork right now which is almost done
so we got to turn it in and like we got
to turn it in and like I think four or
five days